نحن في وسط الدار البيضاء اكبري مدن
المغرب كيف وحدت الانجازات التاريخيه
للمنتخب المغربي جماهير الرياضيه التي
كانت منقسمه في كازابلانكا الرجاء والوداد
يتقاسمين احياء وساحات المدينه
والسبب الملحمه التي يسيطرها اسود الاطلس
في بطوله كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
ورجاوي نقولوا مجموعين كلنا كلنا نتسناو
غير نجاح ديال المغرب يعني وفرحانين
بالنجاح دياله
من منطقتي باب مراكش
ضربه السلطان وساحه الصراخنه الميساجو
العام مو هو نفسه
نشوه التاهل التاريخي من ربع النهائي الى
المربع الذهبي وهيمنه روحي الوطنيه ومشاعر
الوحده
والاعتزازي في انتظار انتصار اخر استثنائي
في ما ارتفع سقف التطلعاته والطموحات
ممكن نقول لهم يزيدك من المستوى اللي
قاعدين فيه وان شاء الله يديه وان شاء
الله كاس العالم
في الدار البيضاء المعروفه بكونها احدى
الواجهات الرئيسيه لسياح القادمين للمغرب
وعاصمتها الاقتصاديه الثرى في بعض زوارها
ومن بينهم هذا الشيء
السعوديات مباراه
يثبتونها الشعب التواد والتراحم ما بينهم
ولا فرح العارمه
وفي انتظار الاستحقاق القادم يبدو تالق
ممثلين المغرب ملهما بالنسبه لشبان مدينه
هي الاكثر كثافه سكانيه في المملكه خليل
الجنود العربيه الدار البيضاء